good morning John today is the day after
Thanksgiving here in America
traditionally the day would we buy all
the things actually more traditionally
in my house is the day when we don't
leave the house because Black Friday
terrifies me people who aren't American
the very ominous sounding Black Friday
is an accident of history back in 1621
it was hard living here in America and
the first English settlers had a really
bountiful crop apparently this is
somewhat mythological and it was on a
Thursday and they were thankful that
inspired a holiday which is a nice kind
of idea for a holiday where you just
talk about the things that you thankful
for I need about food you also read
about it until the 1860s different
states celebrated this holiday on
different days until mmm Lincoln said
this is the day we're gonna have a
National Day in the south was like we're
not even part of you anymore what are
you talking about but then we got had to
get there again that was good and it
became the national holiday the fourth
Thursday in November and because it's a
national holiday on a Thursday you also
sort of get that Friday as a de facto
day off because you don't want to go
back to work for one day and then have
the weekend that's just done in the 60s
because so many people are going on
vacation on this day or to a lesser
extent going shopping this became such a
terrible traffic mess that police and
taxi drivers started calling it Black
Friday as stores and also just general
consumerist culture started pushing the
idea of Christmas shopping further and
further away from Christmas a big block
in the road where you can't push it back
any further is Thanksgiving because
that's its own holiday you can't start
Christmas before Thanksgiving and so
Black Friday became the official tipping
point into The Consumerist Bonanza that
is the holiday shopping season despite
the fact that it has kind of this
ominous sounding name it has been billed
as the biggest and most important and
best holiday shopping day of the year
which is actually not true we are a
nation of procrastinators and thus the
biggest shopping day of the year is
Christmas Eve seems a little bit
upsetting that the day after we all get
done telling the world why we should be
satisfied with our lives we are aroused
with an advertising blitz showing us all
of the things that we lack at the same
time it is very important to the
American economy we can't really get
angry at people for wanting to give each
other things and yes dftba.com has its
own Black Friday and Cyber Monday deals
and you can go to dftba.com and check
those out now it's also our fourth day
anniversary of being a company which is
very exciting
to celebrate that fourth anniversary all
shipping within the United States this
weekend starting tomorrow I think is
just four dollars matter what you buy
but I do think it's important that we
don't just scrub the idea of
satisfaction and thankfulness out of our
brains as soon as we're done for
Thanksgiving and so on this Black Friday
I want to continue being thankful I'm
thankful to my wonderful and supportive
parents to my beautiful and intelligent
and hilarious wife I'm thankful to my
new Wii U if you want to go to
youtube.com slash hankgames you can see
is playing the new super mario brothers
there soon thankful to all of my great
friends here in Missoula and across the
world I'm thankful to finally have a
robust and stable forum that can handle
the weight of nerdfighteria there's a
link in the description I'm thankful to
YouTube and Google for funding scishow
and crash course and for supporting
vlogbrothers and all of our endeavors
through the years I'm thankful to Reddit
and Qi Mental Floss Magazine for making
sure that I keep learning interesting
things I'm thankful to Jonas Salk for
giving away the patent to his polio
vaccine to the world so that it could be
less expensive to manufacture and to Tim
berners-lee for doing basically the same
thing with the internet thankful to the
nerd craft area minecraft server and
tumblr and the Ning and all the other
places on the internet where
nerdfighters do nerdfighter things and
I'm thankful to all the wonderful
thoughtful intelligent people who watch
and support the things that I do on the
internet even when it's snappy silly
videos like this one
and I'm thankful of course for my
brother who's always driving me to do
new and interesting and difficult things
and who's raising a wonderful family and
who says wise and intelligent things on
tumblr and John I'll see you on Tuesday
I know you'll be fine
[Music]